marine le pen la présidente du
rassemblement national n'était pas la
bienvenue aux cérémonies officielles et
du coup celle-ci a décidé de ne pas y
aller
le clan chirac at il eu raison c'est la
question que nous posons à propos de
cette initiative
écoutez la réponse d'alain juppé qui a
été proche parmi les proches de jacques
chirac
et pour lui il n'ya aucun doute oui
c'était la bonne décision
un point sur lequel il a été toujours
totalement d'intransigeance et la
barrière qu'il a posé avec l'idéologie
de l'extrême droite il avait tant en
exécration le racisme et l'antisémitisme
ça c'était une de ses convictions
profondes est donc sacrée entre lui et
le front national une espèce
d'incompatibilité cij qui dessert mais
ça veut dire qu'ils y compris dans les
moments de deuil de recueillement de
rassemblement alain juppé l'aspect
politique le combat politique est
toujours présent l'union n'est pas
possible
les valeurs politiques comme on top
hervé nathan votre votre point de vue je
comprends que les les
ce qu'ils veulent les héritiers de
jacques chirac eux maintiennent cette
position là d'une certaine manière c'est
une forme de fidélité à ce qui a été
jacques chirac mais en même temps quand
on y fait un jacques chirac c'était du
slalom spécial je suis d'accord il faut
se souvient quelque chose quand il dit
le bruit les odeurs par exemple on peut
revenir à ça pour parler du corps social
il n'a pas toujours été du bon côté du
cordon d'abord il ya la sphère de dreux
ou quand même il laisse aller aux
élections municipales des gens de son
parti avec le front national époque ses
fondations à l'époque hein c'est pas le
front ne s'est pas leur assemblée
nationale d'aujourd'hui et c'est aussi
l'époque où il s'est effectivement il
parle du bruit des odeurs qu'est-ce
qu'il dit du milliardaire est dit qu en
fait une forme de des migrations est
insupportable aux familles populaires
qui sont dans les quartiers faux si on
prend toute la séquence un jeu résume
grosso modo c'est est-ce que c'est très
différent de ce que dit le président de
la république d'aujourd'hui quand il dit
les ouvriers eux ils sont confrontés à
l'immigration alors que les monnaies
bourgeois eux ne sont pas c'est ce
qu'ils disent est il le disait avec des
mots nettement plus violent que le
président de mâcon d'aujourd'hui mais ce
que le président macron canton réanalyse
la phrase qu'il a dit devant les députés
de sa majorité c'est pousser c'est
exactement le même phénomène c'est se
situer de la même façon avec des mots
mieux choisir andré bercoff censure sur
cette décision
avions d'abord il ya moi j'ai dû 2 de
réaction qui ne sont pas les mêmes
d'abord la famille a le droit de choisir
gers et la famille elle enterre le père
le mari etc
après tout en tant qu enfin oui vous
avez parfaitement le droit de dire qui
vous avez envie de recevoir et pas ça
c'est l'or c'est leur droit tout à fait
légitime même si je suis pas d'accord
alors quand on dit oui mais les 11
millions de français sont insultés
oui et non je veux dire effectivement on
peut penser je pense juste une chose
dans le malraux des chênes qu'on abat
quand une femme arrive au cimetière là
de colombey-les-deux-églises on la
laisse pas rentrer et sept femmes disent
d'extraordinaire il dit tout le monde il
a dit tout le monde peut rentrer bon ça
après tout c'est à dire il faut pas
éliminer mais c'est le problème la
famille met à jour est rappelée juste en
ensuite de ce que vous avez dit le
programme du rpm des années 90
qwam du rpr cavani c'était à la droite
de marine le pen faut se rappeler ce
qu'ils disaient sur la migration légale
ou illégale le droit du sol droit du
sang le coût de l'immigration
il était extrêmement dur à l'époque
avant tout cas extrêmement précis et sa
disparu tout ça n'était d'ailleurs pas
seulement programme du rpr c'était la
plateforme commune de l'opposition xav
qui réunissait à l'époque jacques chirac
valéry giscard d'estaing à l'injure et
françois bayrou pour déclarer qu' il
fallait arrêter l'immigration le
regroupement familial et que l'islam
n'était pas compatible avec les lois de
la république
alors aujourd'hui romuald quand on dit
ça mais à l'époque c'est passé très bien
daniel bilalian bah écoutez moi je suis
partagé d'un côté mon jeu comme andré
sais que mon la famille décide de clips
revenir à l'enterrement du père de
du mari et en même temps je pense que
c'est pas une mauvaise affaire pour
marine le pen parce que politiquement
elle a eu des mots très simples dit
voilà nous sommes des ennemis politiques
des adversaires politiques mais c'était
le chef de l'état et je représente un
parti très important elle a même dit le
premier parti envoie dans une partie
france et je me dois d'être là il y
avait un côté j'allais dire spécifique
qui faisaient qu'effectivement on
pouvait se poser la question à savoir
pourquoi n'était pas là et par ce geste
elle va sans doute en tirer je pense
qu'elle va auprès de ses adhérents
peut-être en tirer un avantage politique
parce qu'elle a montré qu'elle
respectait la république qu'elle n'était
pas comme on peut l'imaginer l'extrême
droite et caetera et que malheureusement
et bien la république a refusé de la
recevoir ça peut être un argument
politique qui peut lui qui peut lui
servir en tout cas je pense la famille
qui a refusé à la république oui
j'entends bien mais en politique on a la
possibilité de mélanger tout sébastien
pots-de-vin écoutez il a refusé de
débattre le pen entre les deux tours de
l'élection présidentielle en 2001-2002
bon partir de ce moment là que la
famille d écouter on est cohérent avec
ce qu'il a toujours exprimé
ça me semble absolument pas choquant un
land là je veux dire il a refusé donc ne
navigue pas points après regarde tout ce
qui vient de se dire là moi ce qui me
rappelle savoir qu'en trente ans la
problématique de l'électorat frontiste
ou de leur assemblée nationale est
toujours là et lorsque vous évoquez
les propos de l'actuel président de la
république et quand effectivement on les
meilleurs en perspective avec la fameuse
plateforme de l'opposition des années 80
on se rend bien compte aujourd'hui qu'il
y ait une véritable problématique qui
existe à savoir que fait-on des
électeurs de feu le front national et du
rassemblement national actuel et on voit
bien que il la méthode est à peu près la
même essayer de mobiliser autour des
migrations je pense qu'on va parler dans
un point qui suivra mais on voit bien
que les choses demeurent en tout cas sur
le fait de pas inviter marine le pen
sera été complètement abracadabrante
abracadabrantesque pardon de l'inviter
là et ne pas avoir voulu parler que son
père en 2002 en même temps quand on
disait tout à l'heure que jacques chirac
était un peu de jean claude killy d' de
la politique
il a quand il ya comme un gibier nous
avons la photo tous en teck ou bien
serrer la main un jour sur un lieu de
vacances 85 paraît que c'était une
rencontre fortuite eu alors nos
internautes sont majoritaires 57%
ceux qui suivent l'émission actuellement
et qui s'exprime sur twitter a considéré
que le clan chirac n'a pas eu raison de
refuser la venue de marine le pen
donc je reformule de façon un peu plus
clair le clan chirac at il eu raison de
refuser la venue de marine le pen à la
cérémonie d'hommage c'est non à 57 %
c'est le point de vue de nicole qui
trouvent ça que c'est antirépublicain
même si je ne vote pas rm dit elle c'est
quand même 10 millions de français n'ont
représenté alors que babineau estime
qu'il est difficile de contredire les
proches de chirac
la présence de marine le pen dérange car
son parti n'est pas comme les autres et
puis espace tranquille qui nous dit
combattre les mauvaises idées oui les
hommes non une réaction aussi peut-être
sur cette absence mais cette fois ci de
leur fait
des parlementaires de la france un
soumise à la messe qui avait lieu à
saint sulpice au nom de la laïcité vous
paraît une bonne idée des planeurs c'est
vraiment
ça c'est véritablement le côté oeillères
terry fait rage à dire qu'on n'a plus le
droit maintenant de fréquenter une
église au nom de la laïcité quand il y à
une cérémonie un deuil national une
messe alors moi je veux bien qu'on
pousse la laïcité mais j'aimerais bien
que ces grands chantres de la laïcité
car tissage et l'entrée d'une église
soit un peu soit un peu un peu plus
peut-être regardant sur certaines
mosquées salafistes par exemple sur
lequel on les entend pas beaucoup
beaucoup parlé
moi ce que j'aime pas si vous voulez
c'est la laïcité à deux poids deux
mesures c'est ça que je n'aime pas et
vraiment la france a soumis son ordre et
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
enfin après tout alors ça veut dire on
ne va plus dans une cathédrale sous
aucun prétexte
l'on peut y aller tout en l'état a t il
y avait beaucoup d'attenté qui était à
saint sulpice
aujourd'hui les gens qui ne croient pas
en dieu faut arrêter de mélanger tout
tout ça n'est pas très joli
dans toutes les familles
il ya une partie de la famille qui
restent à l'extérieur de l'église qu'il
avoir un godet dans le bistrot en face
en attendant que ça se termine c'est pas
mon cas mais on va pas très bien de
laïcs et aller à l'enterrement de
quelqu'un qui était catholique ou
protestant il n'a pas par déférence par
amitié je propose que ça de dramatique
comme un curé peut aller un banquet
républicain
ah bah c'est d'ailleurs là il ya bien
longtemps que l'église catholique s'est
rallié à la république c'était le quoi
le tos du carnet lavigerie plus en
quelle année c'est aimer ça a déjà une
bonne centaine d'années on va parler
maintenant si vous le voulez bien de la
convention de la droite c'est ainsi que
c'était nommer cette manifestation ça
s'est passé samedi dernier à paris et y
avait relativement peu de représentants
de la droite traditionnelle en tout cas
n'y avait pas d'élus nationaux l'est
républicain il n'y avait pas non plus de
représentants